certains n'ont plus d'un siècle
elles ont connu les routes impériale
puis les nationales ancêtres des bornes
kilométriques
on les appelle les plaques de cocher les
premières plaques d'après entre de 1835
elles ont été mises en place jusqu'à
quasiment la première guerre mondiale
donc c'était l'ancêtre de ce qu'on
connaît de la nôtre sinisation côtière
actuelle dont elle était utilisé à
l'époque par les par les cochers pour se
diriger en général elles étaient placées
à l'entrée et à la sortie de chaque
village
nicolas jamoye et chauffeurs de bus sur
la route ils les poteaux à tous les
jours le temps les à détériorer alors ce
passionné est à leur chevet par plaques
il faut compter une dizaine d'heures de
travail on ôte toute trace de rouille
deux anciennes peintures ensuite en
inventer pour cirage et après donc deux
couches de protection antirouille et
ensuite deux autres couches de peinture
bleue et je finis avec le lettrage en
blanc que je fais ou au pinceau les
panneaux indicateurs proviennent
principalement du loiret et de l'essonne
il en a rénové 70 depuis qu'il a eu le
déclic
il y à un peu plus d'un an avant je
faisais que les photographier et un jour
je suis tombé sur une plaque avait été
rénové j'ai trouvé qu'elle était là
était joli et ça les met plus en valeur
et ça permet de les préserver
dans ce village le conseil municipal a
décidé de lui confier six plaques
elles appartiennent au patrimoine au
même titre que l'église qui a été rénové
l'opportunité a fait qu'on avait une
personne qui avait les capacités et les
compétences et surtout je dirais
une passion pour le faire et en plus
vous savez que les budgets communaux
sont quand même très réduit et là nous
avons à peine payer le prix de la
peinture une fois repeinte les plaques
ont fière allure dans les villages elles
ornent les façades encore pour de
nombreuses années